in the mid-1980s a philosopher and
theologian by the name of james karst
defined these two kinds of games finite
games and infinite games
a finite game is defined as known
players
fixed rules and an agreed upon objective
football baseball there's always a
beginning middle and an end and if
there's a winner then necessarily there
has to be a loser
then you have infinite games infinite
games are defined as known and unknown
players which means anyone can join the
game at any time and you don't
necessarily know who all the other
players are
the rules are changeable which means
every player can play however they want
and the objective is to perpetuate the
game to stay in the game as long as
possible
turns out we are players in infinite
games every day of our lives whether we
know it or not there's no such thing as
uh winning healthcare right there's no
such thing as winning education you can
come in first for the finite amount of
time you're at school where we agree
upon the time frame and the metrics
grades but nobody wins education or
nobody wins learning um uh nobody you
can't be number one in your marriage you
could be number two but you can't be
number one
uh
uh well maybe the first time but
exactly exactly exactly
but then it's finite and you have to try
again exactly the goal is to perpetuate
remember
um
uh and there's definitely no such thing
as winning business
but if you listen to the language of so
many people
it becomes abundantly clear they don't
actually know the game they're playing
in you know i hear people all the time
in business talk about we're number one
or i'm the best
you know or i want to beat my
competition
based on what based on what agreed upon
metrics objectives or time frames
and this is a problem because when we
play with a finite mindset in an
infinite game when we play to win in a
game that has no finish line
then there are some consistent and
predictable outcomes
the big ones are the decline of trust
the decline of cooperation and the
decline
of innovation and if you think about it
everything that i just described like
you don't know who all the other agents
are you don't you know anybody can
become an agent at any time they want
anybody can do their run their business
however they want um and nobody wins you
can you know selling a property is
finite there's a beginning middle and
end okay that's what i was going to
answer uh but then it just repeats and
repeats and a series of repeating
infinite finite games it doesn't make an
infinite game just makes you exhausted